[Music]
here we will showcase the 10 biggest sea
monsters from movies and shows of the
year 2022 even though it hasn't ended we
already know what they are and most of
these creatures have been featured with
a couple of them to be seen in december
so let's get to it
starting with number 10 the thanoport
the thanopod resembled a gigantic crab
its shell was extremely hot and could
act as a protective armor making it a
dangerous foe it could utilize a corpse
as a puppet for human speech implying
that it possessed some type of telepathy
it could also understand english a human
language this thanopod was most likely a
female given that it had children while
aboard a ship this crowd like monster
was blood thirsty and was around eight
to nine feet tall or 2.4 to 2.7 meters
in height
next we have a great white so yeah this
is the only low budget entry on this
list but we needed a shark for this to
be truly a sea monster list
so this was a great white shark from the
movie requiem it was a bloodthirsty
killer with absolutely no regard for the
laws of physics or cgi
but it didn't look monstrous enough to
enter here it was around 5 meters or 16
feet long
number 8 the ilu to be seen in the
upcoming movie avatar 2 the elu is a
massive plesiosaur-like aquatic animal
that rules the waters of pandora it has
a long neck six flippers and a tail that
resembles a rudder this sleek and lean
aquatic reptile closely resembles the
ancient plesiosaur species of earth it
has two neural whips and four eyes it
has a black upper body with multicolored
patterns splutch upon it and a white
underbelly these creatures are 7 meters
or 23 feet long
number 7 the mossosaurus this specimen
is from the documentary show called
prehistoric planet and was a big beast
with an accurate appearance well a more
accurate appearance than the other
mososaurus that will be seen higher in
this list this mostasaurus was smooth
and slender and kind of plumpy as well
as having a red coloration on its upper
half it is a 14 ton sea monster that is
around 59 feet long or 18 meters
number six the worm the design of this
monster from
the series rings of power resembles an
aquatic reptile from the mesozoic era it
had a body similar to a giant
mossosaurus with two large fins in the
front and a large tail with bike on cave
type of flipper fins its head was
monstrous looking and had a horn on its
nose giving off a pacific rim guide you
kind of vibe as it does look similar to
knifehead its back is lined with several
sailfins that are segmented from each
other this creature is around 100 feet
long or 30 meters
number five the brickleback
this monster is an enormous marine
creature that has massive jaws a sharp
horn on its mouth and tentacles are
resembles an arthropod and a body for
fish and it is green in color it also
has a crocodile-like snout which is
another intriguing feature of it seen in
the movie the seabees it is the first
marine master to be featured the
inevitable a ship aided another ship
when it was attacked by this monster so
it returned the favor by attacking the
inevitable the monster is big over 100
to 120 feet long or 30 to 36 meters
number 4 the mossosaurus again but this
one is from jurassic world dominion and
made its appearance briefly in the movie
with only two or three clips of it it
has a large crocodilian-like snout with
sharp teeth and a massive jaw it was
seen attacking a crab fishing ship in
the beginning of the movie and at the
end it was enjoying the company of a
couple of whales which seemed highly
unlikely as they were completely
different species
this mussosaurus was oversized at over
120 feet or 36 meters long
number three the purple crustacean
this is another monster from the movie
the seabees it is just basically a
gigantic purple colored crab with very
sharp outgrowths in its carapace it had
two eyes that stuck out just like those
of crabs and they were around 10 feet in
size alone including the stalks the crab
itself is around 100 feet or 30 meters
tall but had a leg span of over 200 feet
or 60 meters across
it was nimble for its size able to climb
big cliffs and swim fast enough to
escape the red bluster another big
monster from this movie
number two the talkin another sea
creature to be seen in the movie avatar
2 this one is way bigger than the last
entry the tolkien is a huge whale-like
animal that lives in pandora's oceans
the tolkien is extremely intelligent
comparable in intelligence to the navi
people and humans
but in its own special manner like
earthly cetaceans and whales the
mythkyana clan who see them as brothers
are particularly close to the talking
since they are sentient and able to
speak with the navi in a certain way
they are 90 meters or 300 feet long
and number one the red bluster also
known as just red this is the largest
sea monster in the animated movie the
sea beast its body is red in color and
very smooth and slender in design it had
two front flippers and a bike on cave
tail fin on its snout is a very long and
deadly horn which it uses to defend
itself and attack other animals and
ships the red bluster's personality is
kind of like that of kong from skull
island a lone powerful king that
befriends humans who are helpful to it
but it is way bigger than kong around
400 feet or 120 meters in length
and so that's it those are the 10
biggest sea monsters of 2022 so i hope
you have enjoyed watching this video do
hit that like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam